this is buckingham palace as we know it
the official London residence of the
British monarch and a tourist attraction
that's been photographed millions of
times British photographer oliver curtis
turned his back on the palace to capture
an entirely different picture the
picture was taken because I found the
humor of the way people are at some of
these locations particularly interesting
the very unselfconscious they stand in
peculiar ways they do peculiar things
that I'm completely invisible because
I'm just another tourist to them with
this method Kurtis produced unusual
images for his series vote farce it
provides a glimpse behind the scenes the
famous sights aren't visible they can be
guessed at best
for example behind this fog is the Taj
Mahal in India and this is what Oliver
Curtis saw when he turned his back on
the Colosseum in Rome he took this photo
at the foot of the Statue of Liberty now
the longer you spend in one place the
more the landscape yields it starts to
speak back to you and I realized that
one of the things that these locations
have in common is that people spend very
little time there and they have a cup of
tea and ice cream and they go and they
tick the box yeah been there seen it
done it for this project Oliver Curtis
taught the whole world for four years
taking photos in the vicinity of 44
tourist attractions
in 2016 the vote fast exhibition was on
show at the Royal Geographic Society in
London
it all started with the pyramids in
Egypt
Brow's in Cairo on a job and took the
opportunity to visit the pyramids like
any tourist would when I got there I was
surprised by how familiar the place was
even though I've never visited before so
I walked around the base of the pyramid
and found myself looking back out to the
suburbs of Giza and I was really struck
by the incongruous nature of what I was
seeing this brand-new private golf
course sandwiched between the old city
and the deserts and this was the start
of a journey that's also taken him to
Rio de Janeiro and the Lincoln Memorial
in Washington he turned his back on the
Great Wall of China as well as Lenin's
tomb in Moscow there the Lazarus we
looked wrong not at and they're
overlooked in the sense that we look
over them but they're overlooked in the
sense that they're neglected not just
photographically they're neglected
environmentally and then neglected
architectural for now Curtis has had
enough of photographing tourist
attractions
although he discovers one more motif
that Buckingham Palace
we've got three Cowboys over here I mean
for me that is fantastically interesting
it's surreal
if incongruous and it's very funny you
know I would never have scripted that in
a million years and yet there they are
[Music]